SCP-682 Vs SCP-2337. Could the
Hard to Destroy Reptile meet
its end at the dangerously booming
voice of the talkative Dr. Spanko?
As part of a tissue test, Dr. Spanko
was told 682’s flesh was a tone-deaf
food critic who needed to be convinced on
what the greatest food in existence was.
Spanko argued so loudly that the answer was
gummy worms that it destroyed 682’s flesh.
The next step was sending him in
to talk the actual 682 to death,
after being told the reptile was
an “anti-gummy worm extremist.”
This seemed promising until Dr. Spanko
confidently entered the chamber,
and 682 simply boomed “LEAVE”,
at which point Dr. Spanko turned,
literally yelled the wall down, and did
just that. 682 must really hate gummy worms.